so you were one of the first guys to
really get onto the lab leak story where
are we at with that now 18 months hence
yeah so i'll start in the beginning it
was late january of last year like
everybody else i was deeply concerned
about this emerging pandemic and
thinking well where does this come from
and like most people i thought well it
sounds pretty similar to the last sars
outbreak which we knew happened
and it came from nature through markets
but then in late january of last year i
saw
a report in the lancet which showed that
more than a third of the
earliest people being infected
had no contact with that now
infamous uh seafood market in uh in
wuhan
um and then i i kind of had i have two
perspectives one as a person who's
deeply immersed in the world of science
and another as the other part of my life
deeply immersed in asia and china and
geopolitics
and so something just didn't feel right
when the chinese government
kept talking about a market origin
when it was pretty clear to me that the
evidence suggested otherwise
and then i just started digging i really
i dove in and the more i learned the
more the questions were raised about the
possibility of a lab incident origin and
it's still not 100 proven that that's
where this pandemic
comes from um but the circumstantial
evidence is just incredibly strong and
everything we learn at least it seems to
me that it's that it's getting stronger
so yeah i know we'll dig into the
details of this but uh where we are now
uh is in my mind there's a very strong
but still circumstantial case suggesting
a very likely uh but not certain lab
incident origin of the
pandemic
china and is really just outrageously
preventing
any kind of uh investigation into the
origins of the pandemic they're still
engaged in just a massive and outrageous
cover-up involving destroying samples
hiding records imprisoning people in
china for asking questions they have a
gag order
preventing chinese scientists from
saying or writing anything about
pandemic origins without prior
government approval
um there are some efforts to dig deeper
but we need we need a lot more is that
not likely to be potentially the most
evidence that we get
the purely coincidental anecdotal this
is what it seems because
if the chinese government continues to
stumble as effectively as it is at the
moment then
maybe we're never actually going to find
out anything that's concrete it's all
just going to be
best case scenarios
well that that could be that's one
possibility but we also have to think of
how much we and by we i i mean a bunch
of wees there's certainly our group it's
called the quote unquote the paris group
a group of about two dozen experts
around the world who've been
collaborating on this issue since uh
last year uh there's another group and
and there's some overlap between our our
two groups called drastic
which is a group of
they're called internet sleuths but
they're they're more than that um who've
been digging
and and we have uncovered and this
community um
more broadly has uncovered a lot of
highly highly relevant information that
has told us a lot about this this story
so yes it would be better if china had
complete transparency but there's a lot
that we can do
and most people
most people will be surprised
that there's still
no comprehensive international
investigation into the origins of the
pandemic and what that means is if
you're somebody in china maybe a
scientist who has highly relevant
information i'm sure you're scared for
your life
or right now
um there's and you wanted to share that
information there's not even an address
there's there are no secure
whistleblower uh
provisions so there's much more that we
can do will it work will it get us to
100 certainty
maybe it will maybe it won't but we
can't say it won't before we even try
why is there no investigation
it's been a political process
and the main reason is that china has
blocked it
last year in early 2020 australian prime
minister scott morrison called for a
full investigation
after he did that the chinese government
punished australia by imposing trade
sanctions to try to deliver the message
that anybody who dares to ask questions
will be punished
um he and the australians brought that
idea to the world health assembly which
is the governing board overseeing the
world health organization in may of last
year
and there was a jujitsu move by the the
chinese and the europeans played a role
in this as well
and so this idea for a full
investigation
into the origins of the pandemic morphed
into a chinese-supported resolution
which mandated essentially a chinese
controlled joint international chinese
study not into the origins of the
pandemic but into the single hypothesis
of a natural
origin not associated with a lab
incident so that
led to the just the farce
of this international joint study group
um that then the international members
went to wuhan in in january of 20 uh
2021 this year
in early february they held just a
farcical press conference
where in wuhan where they basically
repeated chinese propaganda lines it
comes from nature maybe it comes from
frozen food they said which was
preposterous and they were just later
admitted they were just doing that as a
favor to the chinese
and then
the lead spokesman for this
international
expert team independent expert team
he said we've concluded that a lab
incident origin is extremely unlikely
and doesn't merit further investigation
and it later turned out he admitted he
was lying that wasn't what he thought he
was just doing he had done a backroom
horse trading deal with the chinese who
didn't want a lab incident mentioned at
all so he said all right well i'll say
it's extremely unlikely i'll say
it shouldn't be investigated but is it
okay if we just mention a lab incident
and as i understand
that person is actually under
investigation by the who for doing this
kind of deal i was going to say it's so
crazy that there is no
uh further level of authority that can
look to try and impose on this
particular group when you talk about
an entire global event
each individual nation state kind of
looks after itself but we don't there's
no uh what was that team america there's
no one that's like the global police
that's flying around and trying to
enforce this stuff and um yeah i mean
you know i'm not advocating for a new
world order or uh you know one nation
state across the entire world but we are
seeing here that there is a
lack of recourse
when it's nation state versus nation
state because the only thing that you
have to play with are like trade
sanctions and threats of war and all
sorts of stuff like that which seems
kind of primitive
yeah yeah
that's 100 right and really accurate and
so um the leadership of the world health
organization they're now trying to do as
as much as they can
they have created a group called sago
the scientific advisory group for
investigating the origins of novel
pathogens and that was kind of a
really bold move by dr tedros and the
who leadership
to supersede the mandate that had been
given to them by the the world health
assembly he was basically their bosses
of the of the states and so that's
happening now but china has essentially
condemned uh the dr tedros and efforts
to and what he's called for a full audit
of wuhan labs and access to the raw data
and china has clearly said that they're
not going to allow that and and their
participation in a lot of these
international organizations
isn't designed to strengthen the
organizations but to blunt and and block
them and that's that's really uh really
concerning
right now as we speak uh the there's a
special session of the world health
assembly uh that is meeting to negotiate
what what will likely take many years
which is a new pandemic treaty uh
because it's just a hundred percent
clear
that the institutions and structures
that we have in place right now
for responding to this kind of crisis
are massively insufficient but
ironically after the first tsars uh in
the in 2003 2004 where china had a
similar kind of cover-up in the early
stages
we had the same meeting said we need to
have stronger structures we built them
through the international health uh
regulations and then it didn't make a
difference as a matter of fact china's
behavior this time is even worse it's
even more atrocious
and that leads to your broader question
about just how the world is is organized
and
as you know i'm the founder of an
organization called one shared world and
what we're trying to do is to address
exactly what you said there's a mismatch
between the nature of the biggest
problems that we face which are global
and common
and the absence
of sufficient structures for addressing
that entire category of problems and
that's pandemics climate change
proliferating nuclear weapons and and
lots of
of other things
uh and that's why uh china in the name
of national sovereignty
is able to do all these these things
that certainly i find uh despicable not
just covering up the origins of the
pandemic
but also committing mass human rights
abuses in in xinjiang and tibet and
illegally seizing territory in the south
china sea and along the border with
india
and elsewhere
and that's why we really really need to
think deeply
about how do we build a safer structure
for uh for the world and if we don't do
it unfortunately our world's going to
become a much more uh much more
dangerous place so that's why uh we need
to start moving in that direction and
it's not just about what states can do
everybody has a role yeah there
definitely needs to be more oversight
that's a really interesting way to
actually look at concluding what's
happened to the lab league theory
whether it was zoonotic at a wet market
whether it was a lab leak or whether it
was something else
china is covering up the origin of the
virus it doesn't matter what side of
this debate you fall on
everybody can accept the fact that
trania china isn't being transparent
with the single biggest global health
problem that we've had in the modern era
and that's that blows my mind there's no
recourse for us to try and get those
people back it's
it's crazy
it's really terrible and what china will
say and does say about issues of
xinjiang and and tibet and others is
well the human rights of chinese people
that's china's own business uh the rest
of the world isn't a stakeholder um but
the rest of the world is a stakeholder
the fact that the whistleblowers weren't
able to speak out in the earliest days
following the outbreak whatever the
origin of the outbreak the the fact that
people chinese people who are asking
questions are imprisoned one of them
zhang is actually near death
in in prison that's not just a chinese
issue i mean
economist estimates that the number of
total dead is
due to covet is between 15 and 16
million
i would venture to say that a ver
regardless of the of the origin a very
significant percentage of those deaths
are attributable
to the pathologies of the chinese state
and to this cover-up
so what's been some of the new
realizations that have come out has
there been any data that's arrived
recently updates with regards to the
origin of covid oh huge and and a lot
has has come out and first let me just
lay on on the table the two cases the
people who believe this has a natural
origin they will argue um that that's
how most uh pandemics have happened in
the past
um and uh nature is is very creative and
so we just can't say what what will or
will not show up the counter argument
which is certainly what i
believe is far more likely um is that we
have an outbreak of a uh of a bat with a
horseshoe uh with them sorry of a virus
with a horseshoe bat uh backbone it
happens not where the horseshoe bats are
but more than a thousand miles away
where they don't have this kind of
horseshoe bats but they have the uh the
world's a
china's first and largest highest level
virology institute high containment lab
with the world's largest collection of
bat coronaviruses where they were doing
research not even at the highest level
at bsl 3 and 2
levels
designed to make these scary viruses
even scarier we'll leave the word gain
of function aside for a moment
and then
this
virus shows up and on day one it's uh
with no
parent so far evolutionary history it's
ready
to
easily pass
from human human to human um
and then they have the whole the whole
cover-up since the earliest days of the
outbreak we've had a lot more
information people in drastic uncovered
information that was being hidden by the
chinese about a copper mine in yunnan in
southern china in 2012 six miners were
sent down to clean out uh bad guano bad
manure all of them got sick with what uh
look today very much like sorry like
covet 19 symptoms
half of them died their blood samples
were taken to the wuhan institute of
virology and elsewhere
multiple sampling trips um were sent to
this this same mine
and in those sampling trips uh
a number of many different viruses were
collected
including um one that is among the most
genetically similar to sarsko v2 and
because there's a lot of recombination
in bat viruses just have to assume um
that similarity breeds similarity so
it's quite likely that that there are
additional similar viruses in the
in the collection uh then the wuhan
institute of virology's viral database
with um 22 000 samples
vanished it first went offline and then
vanished in late 2019 and that was also
uh dug up
then we got had access to this
organization eco health alliance which
was a funding partner to wuhan institute
of virology uh and they
were engaged in all sorts of of
activities that certainly from the
perspective of now seem uh seem
questionable
then i could just go on forever but i
won't i then we just uh found out
through a leak and a leak that i think
was a deliberate leak from the u.s
defense department that said hey we did
the right thing
but that
in march of 2018 so a year and a half
before
the outbreak
this organization eco health alliance
along with the wuhan institute of
virology
applied for 14 million dollars of darpa
funding and one of the things that they
wanted to do
was to genetically engineer a furin
cleavage site which is part of the spike
protein basically how these viruses are
able to in best infect human cells if
you're in cleavage site
into
uh the backbone of a sars-like virus and
so the wuhan institute virology was
going to collect the viruses and they
did collect viruses from laos cambodia
southern china and elsewhere and this la
this work was supposed to be done at the
university of north carolina in the the
lab
of ralph barrack
darpa correctly
rejected that proposal but there's a
real question is did the chinese go
forward anyway i think it's actually
quite likely and that's basically in
most fields of advanced science that's
what the chinese are doing they'll
partner with international experts to
learn as much as they need to learn and
then they'll just push forward
doing that thing in china that's why the
first crispr babies were born in china
and lots of
and lots of other things so we're
we're really
learning a lot and the more we learn uh
the more this looks like um it's very
likely a lab incident origin and and the
reason why
we have this pandemic
it's the origin probably but not
conclusively a lab incident origin and
then as we said regardless of the origin
a criminal cover-up
was what exacerbated this crisis and
brought it to scale would you say that
kovid's helped china overall have they
suffered more than other countries how
does that work out yeah so i think
relatively china is better off china's
relative power is stronger now china is
relatively stronger now than it was in
the beginning that doesn't mean it's
been an enjoyable experience for them by
by any means
but to china's credit
they've managed the spread
of the virus inside of of china
certainly more than than has any other
big country
some people
suggest so that raises the question of
could this have been deliberate i don't
think it is and these are really smart
people it's like the dumbest thing ever
would be to say we're going to release a
dangerous highly infectious
pathogen
in our you know one of our big cities
with the goal of infecting our city
first and then the rest of the world
will do a better job of of locking i
don't think that's that's very likely
but i do think most likely there was
some kind of accident followed by a
criminal cover-up yeah that crosses the
line from
aggressive and sometimes negligent to
malicious and mostly psychotic
yes yeah which well yeah i agree i mean
i think and so
you you start out at uh negligent and
certainly ambitious and and negligent um
but then you get to the criminal
cover-up um and that's
that's the thing and the cover-up is
malicious because lots of countries uh
make mistakes uh the united states we
had union carbide we had three mile
island we had the accidental bombing of
the beijing embassy in in belgrade uh
recently there was a a terrible
seemingly accidental uh killing of of a
family and in afghanistan there was the
whole afghanistan debacle lots of
countries make mistakes i'm not
pinpointing china as the only country to
make a mistake or as the only country to
ever have a cover-up but what i am
saying in this case um it's it's
the consequences are pretty awful what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace